before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
[Music]
you invite one and they just insist on
bringing all their friends don't they
thank you
[Music]
they're not even entirely sure that
intro made sense hey why do I suddenly
look differently well
that would be because the bulk of this
video is actually shot before
Russell T Davis confirmed that
they are working on spin-offs
right now it's already being worked on
so while we didn't have any
announcements as to what they are when
they will be coming out or anything like
that
the things that I'm talking about here
you're going to hear a lot of uh just in
terms of the timeline like the tents
that I use is speculative tense future
tense like if this happens or when this
happens and obviously now it has
happened why am I not reshooting the
entire thing well one I'm lazy yeah
I don't think I am actually I overwork
that's a different problem but the other
thing uh the actual relevant thing is
that my opinions that I voice in this
are actually the exact same opinions I
have I'm not gonna have the potential
for a different opinion until we know
exactly what we're getting for spin-offs
and since we don't know that yet yeah
I'm just gonna leave it with past me to
express my feelings mostly of
trepidation about this concept just
realize I will be talking as if we
didn't already know we now do but my
opinion and my thoughts my fears it's
the same as when I said it back when I
shot this so let's get back to the me
with the washed out hair color
uh Doctor Who spin-offs
the concept makes me nervous and it's
something that I feel like
they really appear to want to be pushing
for and like there's
there's no confirmation right now that
Doctor Who's going to be getting
spin-offs but
let's look at a number of factors here
one is Russell T Davis is taking over as
showrunner again
he launched spin-offs previously
Torchwood and Sarah Jane Adventures he
wasn't the only one to do spin-offs
there was class under Stephen Moffett
um but nobody talks or remembers or
thinks about that one very much uh since
that happened but that's one thing and
so since he was
um announced to be the new showrunner
I've seen more than a few people go oh
he'll bring back spin-offs there has
been word from behind the scenes that he
would like to do that there's the fact
that bad wolf Studios where the
production is now being handled that got
bought by Sony and Sony would probably
very much like to have them working not
only on Doctor Who the main show but
also on multiple spin-offs so that they
can have it generate more product more
funds more work and now there's also the
fact that Disney plus is going to be
carrying uh Doctor Who and the not so
distant future and is also going to be
putting some money money towards the
um the show itself exactly whether
that's going to go in production or
marketing or what but they are going to
put some Financial Muscle behind it and
just knowing Disney and it's um
franchising nature I would imagine that
at the very least the possibility of
spin-offs is something that is part of
the appeal of Doctor Who to them because
you know why why get the uh the broad
the streaming broadcast rights for one
show
when it can turn into two or three or
four
so and then there's like tiny things
like this image
um that from some of the Doctor Who
offices like Universe really
like and I'm not mocking the name like
that's fine but like we're really we're
really just immediately leaping into
finding a term for a shared universe
yeah this this doesn't excite me as a
notion
there's a couple reason for that the
first is I'm not a massive fan of any of
the spin-offs well the ones I've seen at
least I have actually never gotten
around to class I probably should one of
these days and I don't necessarily think
that they're like bad or hurt the brand
or shouldn't have existed but like for
me personally as a viewer
Sarah Jane Adventures was fine but it
was skewed at a younger audience I
started watching modern era Doctor Who
when I was in my mid-20s I was too old
to get lashed into the the appeal of it
if my kid had ever gotten interested in
Doctor Who and like at a young age and
I'd hooked her into that maybe like
through her I could have enjoyed it more
that certainly happened with a lot of
stuff she liked when she was younger but
she never went for Doctor Who so that
didn't happen and so just as an adult
watching and I'm like I get why this is
pretty good and there's even a couple of
episodes I'm like yeah that's that is in
fact pretty decent but on the whole I'm
like
it's it's just aimed at a much younger
age group than than I am being able to
connect with it through and then there's
Torchwood which kind of the opposite
problem at least initially going so far
out of its way to be mature and adult
and it was exhausting and Torchwood
would eventually yield some good things
incl whether it be a certain individual
episodes uh especially in its second
series or whether it be an entire series
such as with Children of Earth which is
phenomenal and I've talked about how God
how good that is a while back and my
feelings are still in place but
that's one great series out of four and
it's also the shortest out of the four
so it's five great episodes
out of uh uh four series and like there
are other good episodes but like
collectively so
yeah Torchwood is a very mixed bag for
me and it's not something that gets me
particularly excited
so the first reason why I'm not super
pumped for the idea of spin-offs for
Doctor Who
is that I haven't really loved any of
the ones we've gotten so far now that
certainly doesn't preclude anything from
being good but you know historical
precedent does count for something at
least in terms of expectation and that
doesn't necessarily count for much in
terms of what the actual end result will
be but like in terms of setting my
expectation that's what I have to go off
of
and it doesn't uh it doesn't super
excite me so there's that
there's the fact that I've said
from the very beginning when RTD was
confirmed to be coming back and fans
first started speculating about oh he'll
bring back spin-offs my first immediate
thought and I still hold to this is
can we make sure that the show the main
show is in a good standing and in a
healthy State before we start siphoning
off resources into spin-offs
like
I say this as someone who
didn't especially enjoy
the chimno Whitaker era
like I didn't some people did that's
great I'm jealous I wish I had but I
didn't and my interest right now is
knowing that I am enjoying the main show
more and while I have a certain amount
of trust that that will happen I'd like
to at least have that confirmed
and this is also where I feel like I
just went out I'm not going to say that
they should
never do spin-offs
but I really hope if they do they don't
jump into it right away
because I'll tell you if we get news of
spin-offs
before shooty gotcha's first series
starts like if after the tenant's
specials
they announced and you know Doctor Who
will be back and we have these spin-offs
huh
that will really worry me
because I want the main show to be the
best it can be and feel that it is
gotten into a good place before we start
spending stuff off
it's really hard for me to muster
Enthusiast him for spin-offs off of
something that I don't know how it is
yet
I know that I love Doctor Who as a show
but it does go through a big change
every showrunner and even though RTD has
run the show the show before it's been a
while he's not the same Creator he's
changed he's evolved I don't know what
he's going to deliver I'm very hopeful
for what he's gonna deliver
but don't try and milk enthusiasm out of
me for spin-offs of something that I
don't even know what I think of it yet
like that just feels like asking too
much from me as a fan
and I suppose it's also worth noting
that when it comes to spin-offs
I'm gonna say right now
don't try and recreate the ones you've
already done
I mean obviously Sarah Jane Adventures
you can't uh continue on directly
because sadly we lost Elizabeth sladen
and torchwood's probably not a great
idea since the biggest star in that just
keeps sticking his foot in his mouth
over and over and over again and just
needs to stop
talking
just stop
John please but like nobody seems to be
eager to bring him back right now so you
know what would you base a Torchwood off
just Gwen Cooper I mean I suppose you
could but wouldn't you be better off
trying to build something new rather
than trying to Cobble together a
resurrected version of something that
clearly is not in a state where it's
gonna come back anything like it was
before
so I will say that I suppose there's a
little hope there because there was
there has been
um Rumblings in the fan community that
since the character of Kate Stewart is
coming back
uh that she is getting primed for a
spin-off presumably a unit focused
spin-off which in some ways could fill
the vacuum of Torchwood
um where you know it's a team it's
Earthbound it's dealing with the
incursions that happen when the doctor
isn't here so at a basic core pitch with
the idea is that could be similar to
Torchwood but would uh presumably have a
very different tone to it because it
wouldn't be this ragtag group of Misfits
necessarily more likely a more organized
um sort of force especially if Kate
would be at the helm of that so
bringing her back the announcement that
she's coming back
it gives me some interest
but also some fear because if we presume
that she is being primed for a spin-off
well the fact that they've already
announced they're coming back makes it
feel like they're setting up for
spin-offs right off the bat which brings
me back to please don't please don't run
before you can walk
but at the same time if she is being
primed for a spin-off she is a solid
candidate for one whether she's working
on her own or with unit she's definitely
a character that could work and as she
could carry her own show
so again I'll reiterate I'm not saying I
never want Doctor Who spin-offs to
happen again but the spin-offs have
never held my interest as much as the
main show
so I just want to be sure
that the show is working
and anything that's trying to get me
excited for everything like imagine
if Marvel had announced two years worth
of sequels spin-offs and additional
movies before the first Iron Man was
even out
yeah no I think a lot of people would
have gone uh can we wait and see if we
like this first one and that's kind of
where I'm at I mean granted again RTD
with Doctor Who has a more firms
establishment it's not a Perfect Analogy
but like
it's it's where I get concerned about
the corporate entities involved because
I mentioned Sony and I mentioned Disney
both of whom would have uh Financial
incentive to want there to be more than
just one show
of Doctor Who
and
if that is getting pushed for by them
especially knowing again to come back to
Marvel how much Disney is running some
of its stuff into the ground right now
with frankly an oversaturation of
content while I don't think that
specifically will happen to Doctor Who
because Disney is not getting any
creative control
um so far as we know but just knowing
that that's Disney's mentality
and also knowing that there's another
huge Studio behind the production
company that would also want them to be
producing more stuff
I just really worry that things are
going to be that I'm worried that this
era is going to get pushed out of the
nest before it can fly
I'm mixing my metaphors don't run before
you can walk don't jump out of this
before you can fly like
pick pick a metaphor and stick with it
no I won't but it's just
a point of nerves for me
and I guess sometimes I kind of see it
as my job to
temper the hype a little bit
not that I want to rain on anybody's
parade if you're excited that's great
but it worries me sometimes I think when
I get into fan spaces or fan communities
or fan chats
and everyone just seems to be 100 on
board for something like spin-offs and
I'm over here going
is no one else worried about this
and maybe nobody else is
maybe it's just me maybe I am actually
that old and grumpy and cranky maybe I
actually am the uh Captain buzz kill
that my podcast creating friends have
dubbed me to be
it's the way my brain works I can't stop
it from seeing the ways in which
something might go wrong
and then I have to process it by talking
it out and this is my job now so there
you go
the reason that I don't again I'm not
going to say I never want to see
spin-offs but I want to see them get
rushed I don't want to see them first
thing
do you think I'm being overly concerned
you probably do but whatever your
thoughts are what your thoughts are on
the spin-offs we've already had what you
would hope for spin-offs in the future
whether you share my fears whether you
don't whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about them patreon's what pays the
bills allows me to do this as my living
even if you can't help me there like a
share a subscribe they also help me out
and there's links to various other
things that I do down in the description
I've written books I stream on Twitch
I've got an Instagram I'm on Twitter etc
etc etc
um but don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is whether you are nervous about
spin-offs or excited about them or
completely indifferent
you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin look fulla to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters emu delki Theo
the Boyd toy lowly Becky spark for Nobby
lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
Casper Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
so what they should do should they check
[Music]